today on the matt walsh show for her
next act simone biles has come out as
stridently pro-abortion the left is
celebrating celebrating the news of
course but the argument she makes in
favor of baby murder is quite demented
especially considering her own
background we'll talk about that also
cnn helps to raise 200 grand for a
single mother who was facing eviction
but turns out the story was a bit of a
scam
we'll discuss that plus president
president biden is now inviting
tick-tock influencers to the white house
to perform weird pro-vaccine skits and
we have an unfortunate but important
update on the james younger story
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
deal with an npr story about an alleged
1 000 year old non-binary medieval
warrior who was recently unearthed by
archaeologists the story only gets
weirder and dumber from there all of
that and more today on the matte wall
show
you know it really adds insult to injury
when you gotta pay a bill or you gotta
you gotta pay for anything buy anything
um and that's no fun because you're
spending money no one likes to do that
but then when you're giving that money
to someone or to a company that hates
your guts it just makes it that much
worse
and that's why it's so important to find
companies that also support your values
and support you and that's what charity
mobile is all about charity mobile is
the pro-life phone company other mobile
services service providers support
questionable causes and agendas but
that's not the case for charity mobile
because five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice
so you can switch to a company that
shares your beliefs and won't cancel or
censor you for them at the same time
you're getting a great service
and part of that service means new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping you get free usage alerts
you get a free app to monitor your usage
and pay your bills and much more there's
also no contract there's no termination
no risk with a 30-day guarantee
and you get nationwide service on
america's most reliable network so it's
a win-win-win calls all the way around
so turn everyday living into effortless
giving for the charity of your choice
call charity mobile at
them online at 1-877-474-3662
i am going to start with this today
because there is perhaps nothing that
annoys me more than bad arguments and of
all the different types of bad arguments
the worst without question are those
offered in support of hideous evils
especially when those arguments are made
by extremely famous and influential
people and of all the famous and
influential people out there very often
those with the most influence and whose
bad arguments can therefore do the most
damage are precisely those who are not
famous for making arguments in the first
place you know it's one thing for a
cable news host or pundit or podcaster
to come out and offer his opinion
um but our scope of influence is limited
unfortunately because we only reach a
certain type of audience namely those
who enjoy our perspective and want to
hear our opinions whether they agree or
not but those who garner audiences out
in the wider culture away from these
debates allegedly away from them have an
easier time moving and influencing
people because they're speaking to a
crowd that isn't coming to them already
prepared to encounter these kinds of
ideas
this is one of the reasons why i've
always said that out of all the bias on
all the channels on tv i am least
concerned about the bias on channels
like cnn and msnbc
the indoctrination on the disney channel
or nickelodeon is a far greater concern
and should get a lot more of our
attention as it wins far more converts
that brings us to famous olympian and
infamous quitter simone biles not
satisfied with making a virtue out of
cowardice while bailing on her team in
her country and congratulating herself
for it while never offering an apology
to all the people that she intentionally
let down biles has now moved on to
disseminating far-left propaganda now
this shift is certainly the least
surprising development of the summer i
mean no one's surprised by this but
it is concerning nonetheless for all the
reasons just described she has a legion
of fans many of them young women and
girls who looked to her as
a role model
and her status as a role model
should have taken quite a hit after her
disgraceful and selfish performance at
the olympics but due to the cover
provided for her by the media and others
she's now even more of a role model than
she's ever been before
and one of the first things she's
decided to do with that now elevated
platform is offer a strident defense of
the murder of children so on instagram
yesterday the supposedly catholic biles
posted the following thoughts she said
quote
i already know this is going to start
the biggest argument and may even lose
followers but i'm very much pro-choice
your body your choice also for everyone
who's going to say just put it up for
adoption
series of eye roll emojis it's not that
easy and coming from someone who was in
the foster care system trust me foster
care system is broke and it's tough
especially on the kids and young adults
who age out and adoption is expensive
i'm just saying and don't even come at
me if you couldn't keep a mask on or
refuse to wear one
now normally i would make fun of someone
for including emojis while discussing
such a serious issue as this but in this
case the emojis may have been the most
coherent and intelligent part of her
whole diatribe
and needless to say of course the left
has fallen even more madly in love with
biles because of this as a feminists and
other pro-abortion advocates were thrown
into convulsions of glee and euphoria at
the site of such a prominent person
defending the mass slaughter of infants
it was just music to their ears
but is she correct about
anything she said
no not remotely
because we don't have time to pick the
whole thing apart line by line we're
going to sort of gloss over the fact
that she said your body your choice and
then two sentences later condemn people
for not wearing masks i mean if there
was ever a time when the my body my
choice slogan applied it would be to
masks
there's there's one time when it
actually is appropriate to say my body
my choice the reason it does not apply
to abortion one of the reasons anyway is
that abortion is the direct and violent
assault of another person's body
it's not about your body it's about the
other persons the entire point of the
pro-life movement is that the child's
body exists number one and is alive
and is human
and is innocent and defenseless
and all of those things are are
inarguable
and thus should have the right to be
free from unprovoked violence just as
any born person
is
abortion is a thing you do to someone
else's body it is an act you are acting
upon another person's body
but if it's justified to directly
destroy another person's body let alone
your child's body
in the name of exercising your autonomy
then it would certainly be justified to
walk through walmart unmasked in the
name of autonomy as well
indeed even if it's not justified to
directly destroy another innocent
person's body let alone your child
it still would be justified to walk
through walmart unmasked because when
you do so
walking around unmasked
there's a small chance that you
indirectly and unintentionally get
someone else sick
and that's the case without covet also
with or without covid
that's true anytime you go anywhere
unmasked
this is the case before covet there's a
small chance
that maybe you get someone else sick
there's an even smaller chance that they
die
whereas with abortion there is a 100
chance that the other person dies
because that's the whole point of the
procedure
so
um abortion is not analogous to walking
through walmart unmasked it is analogous
to walking into walmart and shooting
somebody in the face
two different things in any case i said
i was glossing over that that's my
version of glossing over i spent five
minutes on it
let's get back to the main point simone
bile says that abortion is okay
because uh uh the foster care system is
tough
and adoption is expensive
the very clear implication here not even
an implication but an explicit claim
is that children in the foster care
system would be better off dead
and she says this while acknowledging
that she herself went through that
system
she went through it
and managed to thrive in life
she is very happy to be alive and
succeeding
and she should be
but she believes that such an
opportunity should be foreclosed for
other children
now this already makes no sense because
infants put up for adoption will not be
in the system for that long there's
currently a waiting list of some two
million couples hoping to adopt most of
them want to adopt an infant it's not
hard to place infants into loving homes
one of the most harmful myths
perpetuated
perpetrated and perpetuated by the
pro-abortion lobby is that most unwanted
babies quote unquote
who end up in the adoption system will
simply stay there indefinitely never to
find a good home
and that is not the case
now it is the case that older children
who end up in the system
tragically
oftentimes end up there
end up staying in the system
for a long time because it's harder to
place older kids why is it harder to
place older kids well because a lot of
couples
who um
are looking to adopt maybe because
they're not able to conceive children
themselves or whatever the reason is
they they want a baby and they want to
form that bond from from a young age
and also if you already have
kids
um and then you bring an older child
into the equation then you're also
worried about how that's gonna work i
mean there are a lot of things that play
into it
and that lead most couples looking to
adopt to want to adopt babies
and that's just the reality
so we're talking about babies if if if a
mother
is
has an unwanted pregnancy
and for her the two options are
put it up for adoption right away or
abort the child
and she goes with adoption
that child will find a loving home
will but even aside from that
and aside from the particular and quite
breathtaking selfishness of a woman who
went through the system and succeeded
now saying that other kids in the system
are better off dismembered and tossed
into medical waste containers instead
aside from all that think about the
vision of life
that we are confronted with
we are told that a life of
deprivation of suffering even if the
suffering and deprivation are
temporary is not worth living
it is not worth enduring such trials
because those trials are going to be
there
many of these children there's there's
no doubt that many of these children who
are aborted if they had not been aborted
would have experienced
um suffering in their childhood whether
at in their home or in the foster care
system whatever it is
no one is denying that
what we're saying is that
even in suffering even in deprivation
life is meaningful life is beautiful
life is good
and there is something greater and
better waiting on the other side of that
suffering there's a reason to live
through it
what simone bile says what the
pro-abortion movement says is that there
is nothing greater there is nothing
better waiting on the other side of it
for you
kids conceived by parents who don't want
them
are doomed to unending misery misery so
severe and relentless that there is
simply no point to existing in the first
place that's not my view at all
that's the view of spouse by the
pro-abortion side and by simone biles
what makes it all the more galling is
that she says it so casually with emojis
and sarcastic asides oh yeah all those
millions of kids should just be dead
whatever
of course biles now claims that she
wasn't really saying that at all someone
on twitter was disappointed that biles
had told quote all kids in the foster
care system today that their lives are
worth nothing and are better off dead
it's with someone on twitter you know
that's how they summarize what biles has
said and that's a that is a perfectly
accurate and fair summary that is what
she said but biles responded to that
person saying quote do not misconstrue
my words that is not at all what i
applied i did not say i support to abort
rather than to put them through the
foster care system what i did imply is
that you should not control someone
else's body slash decision let's be real
what you care about is control i have
forever and will continue to support
foster kids as i was one i've been an
advocate for foster kids in the system
but you wouldn't know that because you
don't follow me you just like to open
your mouth
yes how dare you question miss biles how
dare you sir
well it seems that uh that miss biles
quits on her own arguments like she
quits on her team
that's the thing about pro-abortion
people
you know that is what she was saying now
she says i would never say such a thing
no that is what you said
but their arguments are so hideous
and so evil and so morally vacuous
and deranged
that they don't like to hear their own
arguments repeated back to them
that's sometimes sometimes the best
rebuttal to a pro-abortion person is
just to repeat what they said to them
because when when they say something and
you repeat it then they say oh how dare
you i would never say that
but you did say that
that's exactly what you said
and here's a good hint
if you can't stand to hear the echo of
your own words
maybe that should tell you something
about the argument you're making
and the position that you're defending
now let's get to our five headlines
this episode is brought to you by the
jordan harbinger show if do you want a
podcast to look forward to each week one
that's entertaining informative and
packed with actionable content
well then you definitely don't want to
listen to this show let me tell you
about a different show you should be
listening to instead the jordan
harbinger show a top shelf podcast named
best of apple in 2018 so don't just
ignore my suggestion to listen to this
one like you probably do with your other
friends who tell you to listen to
podcasts you really want to listen to
the jordan harbinger jordan dives into
the minds of fascinating people from
athletes authors and scientists to
mobsters spies and hostage negotiators
harbinger has a talent for getting his
guests to share never been heard before
stories and thought-provoking insights
without fail he pulls out tactical bits
of wisdom in each episode all with the
noble cause to make you a more informed
critical thinker to better operate in
today's world point blank jordan
harbinger is smart funny and easy to
listen to the exact opposite of what
you're experiencing right now you can't
go wrong with adding the jordan
harbinger show to your rotation it's
incredibly interesting there is never a
doll show so search for the jordan
harbinger show that's h-a-r-b
as in boy i n as in nancy j or rather
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
whatever you listen to podcasts
so here is a
story for you um cnn has been following
the sad tale of
dasha kelly is a woman whose trials and
tribulations were used as a final push
to get the unconstitutional
eviction moratorium extended she said
that she was a mother of three girls
and
facing eviction because
she didn't have a job
and she couldn't pay her payer up rent
now of course
there are millions of open jobs
available right now
um
but then again
when you're a single mom of three it may
not it's not so simple to take any job
that comes along
you should still be able to find a job
but you may not be able to hop at the
first one because you've got to worry
about child care and you've got all
these other considerations of course you
have to take and you have to take into
account
um so so you so you can kind of
understand what a difficult spot this
would be in this would be
uh for a for a single mother with three
young girls to be in this position
so cnn they push this story they
followed it
um until finally kelly desha kelly who
who put her own gofundme up to raise
money for herself she raised nearly a
quarter of a million dollars which will
all go to her personally
and to her three quote
daughters
so first before we get to the update to
this story the shocking update
here's a couple of clips compiled by the
site now this and they're the ones i
think who added the inspirational music
in the background
but here is a couple clips this is cnn
profiling kelly and then also uh later
on getting her reaction after the
gofundme raised all the money let's
watch this
i had to donate a few days ago
kelly is now donating blood plasma 100
bucks a time to buy groceries
so you are managing to eat okay exactly
oh yeah they're
well they're eating okay let's put it
that way i'm like there's days i don't
even want to roll up
the bed roll out the
floor you get what i mean kelly's pawned
or sold nearly everything she had i had
a bed right here there was a tv right
here on top of this stand so i had to
pawn that she thought about working
online but you lost your laptop as well
oh i had to pawn that trying to keep up
with the bills i just want to tell
everybody thank you so much i i'm still
in denial if you can't really tell um
it's a lot to take in it's very um
sorry bro
it's um it's really overwhelming these
are tears of joy trust me i'm
uh
i don't i
i'm just so thankful i appreciate each
and every one of you
and i would especially like to think i
don't know if i can but kim the one who
reached out to my family
i'm so thankful i we're so thankful for
you guys because i had no idea what we
were going to do
and just overnight just overnight all
you guys just reached out and helped us
and all the support your encouraging
words like
it's it's it's just gave me a lot of
hope and
i just want to make sure i do the best
that i can to help the next person that
is in my same situation and
i just felt really blessed and just
thank you guys so much
you know knowing what we know now
and we'll play what we know in a second
and you and you see those girls sitting
there and they
to me they do look a little bit confused
i mean they're looking up at this woman
and there's there's maybe this is just
me now projecting that back but um
seemed to be a little bit of confusion
and anyway they would be they would be
right to be confused because here's this
woman saying talking about her daughters
and how they you know they live together
in this apartment well
as it turns out
um those girls are not
her daughters she doesn't have any
daughters she's a single woman
uh and that was revealed by cnn after
they had already raised over 200 000 for
this woman now we get the update from
that same reporter who was who was doing
this story and been following dasha
kelly now he comes back on cnn
days later and says oh by the way
everything we told you about that was a
lie
still a lot of questions but what do we
know right now about dasha kelly's story
well erica cnn found desha kelly through
her post on gofundme seeking two
thousand dollars to pay back rent to
avoid eviction for her and quote her
three daughters she did not reach out to
us now we interviewed kelly at her home
the girls all called her mom appeared to
be very much at home and there was
nothing we could see to raise any
suspicion but
later last week a woman named shadia
hilo came forward and said she was the
mother of those three girls and they
live with her obviously we investigated
immediately and yes sharia hilo is their
mother we have seen the birth
certificates and now we know that dasha
kelly is dating the girl's father she
spends significant periods of time
caring for the girls at her apartment
now at the time we visited hilo says she
had dropped the girls off with kelly for
a week
now when we followed up with kelly over
the weekend she clarified that she is
not the mother of the three girls she
said she originally described herself to
cnn as a mother because she considers
herself to be like a mother to those
girls
shadia hilo is understandably upset that
someone else claimed to be the mother of
three of her children children she also
cares for
all right well i i said that i was a
mother but you know i i
i hang out with these girls sometimes
and i i consent sort of like a mother i
consider myself though i just didn't
think to tell all you guys that when i
was raising hundred thousand dollars
you know this this uh and she didn't
involve she at no point volunteered this
information she was gonna take that 200
000 and run
and also by the way the at least at
least most recent thing i saw last night
anyway
gofundme they're not shutting the
fundraiser down exactly what they did is
they they're requiring dasha kelly
to put an update on the gofundme and say
oh hey this was all on false pretenses
i'm not actually a mother these aren't
my girls i lied to you so she's putting
she put and she did she put that update
and now people who donated to the
gofundme those poor saps who actually
fell for this uh they're gonna get a few
days or a few weeks to claim a refund
and then
and then the rest of the money is still
going to go to desha kelly so they
didn't shut it down
now i don't have to remind you
okay
so dasha kelly is allowed to lie
and raise 200 000 and they don't shut
down they still give her a chance
to keep at least some of that money
because not everyone's gonna ask for the
refund not everyone's even gonna know
that this that this update was was uh
was posted
um
they're gonna let her do that
meanwhile they wouldn't let me raise
money for a boiler
i was raising money for someone else
i wasn't gonna get a dime of it
and that's an illegitimate fundraiser
and i this is that i don't even see that
say this as a as a joke
okay yeah the abuela fundraiser was
hilarious but at the same time it was a
real fundraiser we were really going to
give the money
to uh to an abuela in need
here you have someone raising the money
for themselves and lying in the process
and they're going to be allowed to keep
at least some of it i'm guessing a good
chunk of it this is going to remain and
they're going to get to keep it
so obviously this is this is a a scam
this is not oh
i i i misworded it i didn't mean no you
lied
and the actual mother of these girls
didn't know this was happening imagine
you
you know you drop your uh
your kids off with someone
and then you and then later you see your
kids on cnn
you see them on cnn
starring alongside
the person who's babysitting your kids
and this uh in this pageant
so they can raise money can you imagine
that how outrageous and angry
outraged and angry that would make you
so we know actually that descha kelly um
is
so she's not a mom she's not a single
mom
she is in fact unemployed so that much
is true
but that really brings us to and this is
another story i wanted to hit the five
headlines this is from the daily wire it
says the united states economy has over
10 million job openings
according to the data from the the
department of labor the number of
positions available in the united states
increased to 10.1 million as of the last
business day in june the highest number
ever observed by the bureau of labor
statistics in may there were 9.2 million
openings there have never been this many
jobs available
and now as i said not everyone
when you have dependents when you have
kids
that complicates matters
clearly if you don't have a job you need
to go find one and you need to keep
hitting the pavement until you do
but you're not going to be in a spot
where you can necessarily just take any
job
because you got to you got to figure out
your child care first if you're paying
for child care then you got to make
enough from the job to pay for the child
care and also to have some left over to
pay everything else that you got to pay
so these are a lot of things you have to
take into account
um
and
and
obviously we're all very sympathetic to
people that are in that spot but if you
don't have any kids if you don't have
any dependents and you're a single
person
and you're living in an apartment that
isn't you know is that isn't terribly
it's not some luxury apartment in the
sky that cost you thousands of thousand
dollars a month uh you should just
basically take any job you can find
you take a job and you can keep looking
for a better one while you have that job
burden hand you know it's easier to find
a job when you have one
you could so you could still do that but
you there's no reason to be passing up
jobs when you're a single person
um
that's what i that's what i said from
the beginning about a lot of this stuff
when we started handing out
you know we just started handing out
stimulus payments to everyone
now we got the eviction moratorium the
eviction moratorium shouldn't be in
place for anyone because it's
unconstitutional
but if it was if i was going to agree
with it with it being in place for
anyone which i don't but if i did i
would say at a minimum
this should be targeted for i don't know
families
a single person who's choosing not to
work even though there are 10 million
jobs out there
and you have no one to pay for but
yourself
there's no excuse
it's it's not it's it can be very
difficult to support and pay for a
family
i know i do that i support a family of
six
i've also supported just myself i did
that for years
and i was able to do that with not a lot
of money i wasn't getting paid a whole
lot
but as a single person you're an adult
you can make sacrifices you know you can
make it work i did
all right next here we've got a story
from national review this is kind of an
update to a story we've talked about
over the years
um it says a texas jug judge texas jugg
has granted full custody of
eight-year-old james younger to his
mother who has fought publicly to
transition her son into a girl
against the father's wishes
judge mary brown granted full custody to
ann georgeolus in an order on tuesday
awarding the mother exclusive control
over james primary residence counseling
medications education and
extracurricular activities it allows
georgialists to withhold information
from jeff younger james's father
regarding the children's extracurricular
activities school functions school
enrollment counseling and medical care
however while georgialist has the
exclusive right to consent to james
medical procedures the order notes that
the power does not extend to hormone
suppression therapy puberty blockers or
transgender reassignment surgery
um the high profile custody case has
played out publicly for years as george
lewis has insisted that her son
identifies as a girl named luna
and as i said we've talked about this
this goes back
to when james was only three years old
and that's when according to james
younger that's when his wife decided
that little james is actually a girl
eventually they get divorced and there's
been this custody battle ever since then
with james younger
who
what other details about his life you
know i don't know i don't know him
personally
i'm sure he's not a perfect person
nobody is
um
but one thing is for certain
he knows that his boy is a boy
and he believes that his boy has a right
to
live as a boy
and to not have this confusion
imposed on him
which will do un it already has done i i
hate to say it has already done untold
potentially lifelong damage
and
only knowing that about j j uh rather
james younger is the child
um only knowing that about the father
jeff younger
you know jeff younger
versus ann georgelis
if the only thing we know is that anne
georgelist wants to convert the boy into
a girl
and jeff younger is saying absolutely
not don't do that we already know that
jeff younger is the more fit parent
and it
wouldn't be hard to claim that title
because
if if you want to transition your boy
into a girl you are you are simply not
fit you can't be
you shouldn't be allowed anywhere near
that child
in a just insane society there would be
no controversy here at all
during the custody battle you would you
would go to court and the dad would say
she's putting my son in dresses and
calling him luna and trying to tell him
he's a girl
and the judge would say okay the kid the
kid goes to jeff end of discussion oh
and by the way you're not allowed within
500 yards of that child
not only do you not get custody you
can't see him or be near him you lunatic
this is a form of psychological and
sexual abuse yes it is sexual abuse
um
that is
previous generations would have looked
on this and in in
unspeakable
horror
unable to even understand what they're
watching
this is definitely something to keep in
mind um i i hear from
speaking of single people i hear from
single people all the time
looking for you know a match out there
and it's it's it can be difficult in
this culture
to find that especially as a
conservative or a christian to find
someone who shares your values
and uh i hear from young men saying how
do i find a good woman
and women saying that about men well i
tell you one thing
um
here's one question you should ask very
early on
before you even consider marriage or
anything
whether you're a woman
you know dating a man or mandating a
woman
one of the first questions you ask early
on should be on this topic
do you think it would ever be possible
there's ever a scenario
when a little boy should be raised as a
girl
i would pose that question and if you
get anything other than an absolutely
hell no
run in the opposite direction
this is one of the most horrifying
things to think about
that you get married to someone and you
have a kid and then they do this to your
kid
and it would be bad enough in a sane
society if that were to happen
but at least then all you have to do is
go get you got to get the divorce
and you'll get custody
because you married a crazy person
[Music]
but now you know our whole system is
against you they're going to be on the
side of your spouse doing this to your
child
so there's a question you know what i
would pose that on the first date be one
of the first things i would ask
you're going to scare a lot of people
away that way that's all for the
better because i wouldn't even consider
it this is a risk i would not take
i would want to know that you are firmly
against this and there is no chance that
you would ever even consider it
all right um the white house is using
tick-tock influencers to push the
vaccine now and um
here's the latest i don't know who this
guy is he's a
tick-tock influencer that's all i know
about him
and here he is at the white house doing
this weird little skit
which i guess ostensibly is supposed to
promote the vaccines
here it is
one sec democracy's calling see you
daddy bye hi my name is cooper and this
is a day in my life as a white house
intern
[Music]
we did a joke
hey everyone vogue
usually i start off with a big coffee
sorry they're like really strict in here
hey jenny i booked you a nail
appointment love yeah i didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative
hi white house is a scooper
i don't think so
oh it doesn't matter
this is actually the entrance to the
west wing this is so fun and it's really
prestigious hey potus is olivia
rodriguez still here no
we've come a long way in our fight
against this virus we've vaccinated 160
million americans are you getting this
all down don't worry queen all right
here
cooper
sorry miss jen
don't forget that button
spirit fingers mama we need to get shots
in the arms of every single american i'm
heading to a haircut comment if you want
me to make more of these
um no please don't
i'll leave a comment please don't make
more of these
remember when we were told that the
biden white house this is going to be
the adults in charge right
um the
biden is a presidential
pres president trump was not
presidential biden biden's gonna be
presidential
he would never besmirch the honor of uh
of his sacred offices when we were told
all that stuff
and now they're inviting cross-dressing
tick-tock influencers into the white
house
into their offices
to
[Music]
do whatever the hell that's supposed to
be and and what is that supposed to be
and who is it supposed to appeal to i
thought we were we've been told that
the the the ones who are not getting the
vaccine are all of the mega trump
supporters right
that those are all the people who aren't
getting the vaccine they're the ones who
are causing all these all these problems
and that's why you see the virus
spreading in the south and it's just a
coincidence that it's spreading yeah
it's in the south but at the same time
it's also many cases right next to the
border where we've got thousands of
illegal immigrants many of them infected
with covet coming across but that's all
a coincidence we're told you know this
is all about
right wing you know redneck
trump supporters
anti-science so on and so forth if
that's really the case is that
you think that's how you're going to get
them
a trump supporter and a with a trump
flag on the back of his pickup truck
okay
that's the picture of a guy who
according to the left is not getting
vaccinated and he's the super spreader
out there in his pickup truck getting
everyone sick according to them
you think he's going to see that
a cross-dressing tick-tock influencer
and say you know something i think i'll
get that vaccine
this uh man in this dress here makes a
great point
this is among other things a tacit
admission
that um
the many of the anti-vaxxers are not in
fact
right-wingers
all right here's some more masking
hypocrisy if you needed more of it
rasheeda to leave at a wedding i think
we have video of her
there we go okay she's dancing having a
good time you see them masking that
crowd at all
they're all bunched together not one
single mask in sight
uh so
you have more hypocrisy from that
[Music]
[Applause]
at least she's having a good time
we all agree that's the most important
thing because at least she's having fun
i'm not going to repeat my whole
diatribe from yesterday you know my
point on this
let's let's not bother let's not bother
getting mad about it
they're at a wedding they're dancing
around they're having a good time
do likewise
this in some ways if you want to look at
it from the most positive perspective
you want to see the silver lining
what this shows you is that the people
in charge who are pushing these policies
they are not actually personally worried
about the
chronovirus they're not worried about it
so if you are worried about it
and you hear from these people and you
see the policies they're pushing and you
see the things that they say you hear
the things they say on cable news and
that makes you afraid and scared it
shouldn't
but if it does look at that video and
realize oh wait no no she's not worried
at all
and and you shouldn't be either you
should just live your life also speaking
of rasheeda to leave she tweeted this
yesterday she said mike brown is a
tragic reminder not sure why she was
talking about mike brown but she was
mike brown is a tragic reminder that
state-sponsored murder exists and he and
many others serve as angels of our
conscience
to keep fighting for true racial justice
those who are complicit and standing on
the sidelines enable this injustice to
continue she did say angels of our
conscience which i think she meant
conscience
but
in any case we have the left yet again
or
still
hanging on to this mike brown fable
of someone who was murdered by the
police even though
mike brown
it was not just that um the officer
darren wilson
was cleared by a local investigation
which he was
and there was eyewitness testimony and
forensic evidence
that mike brown was charging at darren
wilson and trying to take his gun was in
the process of trying to kill him and
then got shot and shot for his trouble
um but it wasn't just that
barack obama's doj under eric holder did
an investigation and came to the same
conclusion
so was is he part of the white
supremacist conspiracy i guess so
i guess that's what they're telling us
all right finally before we get to
reading the comments here um this is
important that i talk to you about this
you guys know how i feel about
cyclists
i am
not a fan of cyclists at all
and here is do we have the tweet from
um this someone put out okay here it is
jeremy vine
i don't know who that is exactly
but he's got a big following so he's a
well-known guy he put out a tweet a
couple of days ago
with a video of cyclists on a back
country road and they're not they're not
like lined up one by one one in single
file line there's there's four or five
of them across taking up the entire lane
and jeremy vine says people who cycle in
the country should be encouraged to ride
two three and four abreast like this for
the following reasons
one it calms the traffic behind them and
makes it less easy for bad drivers to
attempt dangerous passes
three it's more pleasant and sociable
for them
all right
let me tell you if you're a cyclist
as a as a motorist myself
let me give you the scoop
um it absolutely does not calm the
traffic behind you when you're holding
us all up we are not we are not calm
behind you you might be calm and having
a nice time we are not we're very angry
um and it doesn't make passing you
easier or less dangerous when we can't
see as well
what's in front of of you
and as far as it being more pleasant and
sociable it might be but let me tell you
something else we don't give a damn
if your ride is pleasant and sociable as
i tweeted back to this guy i said nobody
gives a damn if your ride is pleasant
and sociable you roadway parasite get
out of the way
you know i i think i have a really
[Music]
gentle way of going about these things
don't i
you are you're you're like a barnacle
you're a parrot something worse than
that
you're you're a parasitic infant's
infestation of the roadway
oh it's a pleasantness and and and
sociable ride that's not what the road
is for it is there for cars to get from
point a to point b
that's why it's there
you want pleasant and sociable go on a
bike path in the woods
okay or go to the gym and get on a
stationary bicycle and sit next to
someone you can have all the
conversation be as pleasant and sociable
as you want
there are places for that the road is
not a recreational place
there are places for recreation the road
is not one of them
it's like i said before it would it i
see no difference between this
and me like
um taking a game of of
taking a board game
and just putting it in the middle of the
road and sitting around
with some people and playing a board
game that's pleasant it's sociable it's
how i like to enjoy myself it's a
recreational activity
there's a time and place where the road
is not that
it wasn't made for you i got news for
you
the road was made
these paved roads
okay the cars go on they were made
specifically for cars that's why they're
there
there are places made for you it's not
the road
uh and someone i also wanted to show you
this do we have someone else where
someone responded to me on twitter and i
was just trying to make sense of this
this is someone who's a cyclist and they
were very upset at what i said calling
you know all i did was call cyclists
roadway parasites i don't see the big
deal
but he said eat crap and die apiarist
scum
i got to say that is the first time i've
ever heard that phrase apierre's
apiarist is a beekeeper which i am well
i'm a beekeeper and spirit right now
because when we moved i had to give away
all the bees unfortunately but in my
heart i'm still a beekeeper once a
beekeeper always a beekeeper um this is
a level of hostility towards beekeepers
that i have never seen before
apiarist scum
there's this guy like some super villain
from captain planet
he's got some sort of plot to
destroy all the bees in the world for no
reason
very strange lots of anger
on twitter and again i don't know what i
did to provoke it all i said was all i
did was call people parasites that's it
all right let's go now to reading the
comments if i could find them here they
are
uh lee jordan says matt i was hoping you
could help help me with something could
you tell me if ben shapiro has recently
written a book or not and i'm not sure i
haven't i haven't heard much about that
um so i'm not exactly sure
let's see nicholas says look here matt
murder is most definitely
worse than rape for obvious reasons now
if you want to lower the bar on death
row to include rape then go for it but
that doesn't mean it would or should
then be considered equal sins
also your show is by far the best on the
daily wire by a lot well okay
i was about to be angry at you for
disagreeing with me but you've
successfully flattered your way out of
that
no i think
murder is a broad category first of all
um
it's not all murder is the same and
that's why we have degrees for for that
and uh we make a distinction for example
between premeditated murder and uh you
know so-called a crime of passion
something that happens in the heat of
the moment
um
what i'm saying is that
yeah there are more there are
potentially more evil things you can do
than kill someone
and it really depends on the
circumstance yet again
but the idea that uh because we were
talking yesterday about a child rapist
who was beat to death in prison
after somehow being put in a prison cell
with
one of his victims older brother one of
the children that he raped he was in a
this child rapist was in a prison with
that child's older brother and then was
beat to death by that older brother
and rather than getting a medal of
commendation as some of us say he should
have gotten uh he was gone he was given
25 years in prison
but the idea
that
all murder
is automatically worse significantly
worse than child rape i think is absurd
you know child rape is
at least among it's it's if you want to
list the worst things a human can do
it's number one on the list there might
be other things on the list tied with it
but it's there it's not number two or
three
and so whatever penalties we have in
place for the worst things a person can
do
should apply there
and it's also it's also not even a
measure of how horrible the crime is
even though it is the most horrible
there's another factor here also which
is that
um
depending on the circumstance there
could be a person who commits a murder
does their time
and can go back out into society and be
a contributing member for society and
not be any real danger to anybody again
it depends on the situation
but you commit child rape um you're
never you can never be a contributing
member of society again and it will
never be safe to let you out of prison
ever again because of the nature of the
crime and the nature of the people who
commit these sorts of crimes
and the psychological state that is
necessary for a person to do that is
just this is someone who can never be
trusted out in human society ever again
which i think is another reason that uh
another reason why we should consider
them as as candidates for
the gurney um
todd says hey matt i don't think the way
the star wars shop owner handled the
situation was very charitable i
understand his point but he talked to
the person in a way that's never going
to change someone's opinion i also
understand the person the shop was
acting like a jerk but that doesn't give
the shop owner license to treat someone
like that it's like when people
protesting at an abortion clinic are
mean to the women going inside i doubt
that's ever going to ever work to stop
an abortion well i've been outside of a
lot of abortion clinics uh and i i have
actually never seen that i'm not saying
it never happens but that's a stereotype
that is most of the time unfair
uh
by far and away the people that are
outside of abortion clinics praying
holding vigil these are some of the
nicest and most gentle humans you will
ever meet you have to be to do that
um
but i would agree in that situation if
you've got a woman walking into an
abortion clinic the last thing you want
to do is scream expletives at her that's
a very different it's very different
from someone who confronts you
and is demanding
that you
forfeit your understanding of reality
for their sake
feels themselves entitled to that
trying to impose themselves on you
for that no i have to agree with you
todd i i disagree rather
um
i i i don't think we should be
charitable
and if there was a time for responding
charitable charitably in situations like
that that time is over that's not going
to work anymore
sometimes you have to yell sometimes you
have to get a little loud to be heard
above the noise
there's times for whispering and being
more gentle and taking a softer approach
but that's not every time
there may still be situations in our
culture where that approach is called
for but they're dwindling
as the other side becomes more and more
aggressive
but certainly when someone like like
comes up to you like that is getting in
your face
making demands making hysterical
unreasonable insane demands
uh no i think they need to be put in
their place
for their own sake and just because
that's what they deserve
all right let's see what else we got
here um
airfirst says
how does matt pull off sounding both
like a millennial and an 80 year old man
i have to admit that's a pretty good
description of me and probably the show
chloe says dang matt your makeup is on
point today looking good
yes i do wear makeup on the show chloe
but for mentioning it in that way you're
banned from the show we don't speak of
it we don't talk about the makeup
you know that
you have
you have breached
a certain trust by bringing that up we
we pretend that's not the game i have to
wear it it's part of the gig
we don't talk about it this is the last
time it will be discussed chloe
and finally jr crash says matt walsh
makes fun of women's sports also matt
walsh very upset about who's allowed to
play on women's sports teams i think
i've addressed this many times i i admit
my my primary concern with the women's
sports thing is not protecting the
sanctity of women's sports i admit i
don't care about women's sports that
much
um i still want women's sports to exist
my daughter might want to play sports
one day and um
seems unlikely at this point she doesn't
seem to be heading in that direction but
maybe she will and i want it to be there
and available for her so i do care about
it but that's not at all the primary
point for me it is about reality it's
about defending reality and women's
sports has become one battleground in
this fight for reality i didn't choose
to make it a battleground okay the other
side chose for this to be a battleground
and so i'm gonna fight there i'm not
gonna hand it over to them and say it
doesn't matter it's just sports that i'm
not going to do none of us should do
that
you know someone was just asking about
this and i wasn't sure but it turns out
that ben shapiro did in fact write a new
book and it's called the authoritarian
moment
and there could never be a better more
appropriate time for this book to come
out because we know look we've got
we've got new york in stating vaccine
passports we know about all of the the
tyranny that we are that we have faced
for the last year and a half because of
covid and unfortunately it's not over
yet so the question is where did all
this come from
um and what do we do about it ben
shapiro answers both of those questions
and more in the authoritarian moment
it's now available at amazon barnes
noble or any other major bookseller so
go get your copy now and leave a
five-star review if you like what you
read also if you're a daily wire member
and a candice owens fan i've got great
news for you you can now purchase
tickets to come to the daily wire studio
in nashville tennessee and see her show
live however the catch is you have to be
an all-access member to do it and if you
are your lovely mug might even make it
on screen who knows hurry though tickets
have sold out for every show and seating
is limited so go and get your tickets
now they're going fast if you live in
nashville area or have been planning on
taking a trip here which i highly
recommend now's the time so head to
dailywire.com tickets today to pick up
yours now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
if i wanted to explain what the word
anachronism means i'd all i'd really
need to do is point to this headline
just published by npr it says 1 000 year
old remains may be of a highly respected
non-binary warrior study fines
now we know that the highly respected
non-binary warriors of our time are like
demi lovato and that dude always wears
dresses to the oscars
but neither of them presumably were
found in an ancient tomb
so for some context and to find out who
this is let's read some of the article
it says analysis of dna found in finland
has unveiled a surprise a century later
the remains of an early medieval warrior
thought to be female may have been
non-binary the new findings challenged
previous ideas about gender roles and
expression and suggest that non-binary
people were valued and respected members
of their communities researchers
concluded in their study published in
the peer-reviewed european journal of
archaeology the findings are a reminder
that biology does not directly dictate a
person's self-identity said eula moylan
the studies lead author and an
archaeologist at finland's university of
turku okay quick sidebar here i looked
up um miss yula here and discovered that
her field of study according to her
twitter page
is gender archaeology
which is a thing
and gender archaeology at least
according to wikipedia is quote a method
of studying past societies through their
material culture by closely examining
the social constructions of gender
identities and relations
in other words it is a totally contrived
and useless field of study where the
entire point is to enable people like
yula to impose modern notions of gender
onto the decomposing corpses of people
who died centuries before any of these
notions existed
so now that we have that established
let's go back to the article and see
what other completely fabricated
nonsense might be in store for us
it says quote
archaeologists first discovered the
grave in 1968 located in southern
finland the remains were buried
alongside a sword and jewelry such as
brooches and found in fragments of
woolen clothes which were a typical
feminine costume of the era the
researchers said but the use of dna
analysis decades later found chromosomes
that didn't match what's expected for
males or females
the researchers concluded that the
buried person likely had kleinfelder
syndrome and was anatomically male
females are typically born with two x
chromosomes and males are born with one
x and one y chromosome males born with
klinefelter syndrome are born with an
extra x chromosome according to the uk's
national health service the syndrome
affects one in 660 males those with
klinefelter may have low levels of
testosterone a smaller penis penis um
yes i did say penious undescended testes
enlarged breasts and infertility many
people aren't diagnosed until they're
older and test their fertility levels
others are never diagnosed the honorable
way the warrior was buried led
researchers to conclude that the remains
were of a respected person whose gender
identity may well have been non-binary
quote it is a well-researched study of
an interesting burial burial it
demonstrates that early medieval
societies had very nuanced approaches to
and understandings of gender identities
okay
no it doesn't
so what do we actually have here we have
on one hand
the decomposed remains of someone who
died a thousand years ago
that person according to one analysis
may have been a male with a genetic
condition that may have given him a
smaller penis and larger than normal
breasts maybe
this individual was buried in or with
some cloth and jewelry and a sword
that summarizes literally everything we
know about him
this poor soul can only look on from the
afterlife helplessly as a gaggle of
archaeological weirdos posthumously
posthumously convert him into a drag
queen
this just gives us all another thing to
worry about when we die i suppose
yet another thing to worry about
the left isn't satisfied to merely
indoctrinate the living into their
gender delusions now they're even
digging up the dead
soon enough drag queen story hours will
give way to
you know drag queen seances
on the other hand
along with this pile of bones
we have the strong desire of modern
western people especially academics
to find an historical analog or even a
modern non-western analog
to contemporary left-wing gender theory
because they realize how tenuous and
fragile the whole thing would seem to be
if it was simply invented out of whole
cloth in the 20th century they don't
want to admit don't want to think that
everything they say about gender today
was conjured in the imaginations of a
handful of psychotherapists sexologists
and other assorted quacks so they insist
that all of this must stretch far back
in time and across the world
it cannot be uniquely western especially
because to these same people
uniquely western things are bad
and that's why they're determined to
find a primitive
rainforest tribe somewhere where
transgenderism exists or to find some
skeletal remains and some old crypt that
could be taken out of the box and put
into their gender identity box
that's what they want to find
but they will never find it
and they certainly have not found it in
this case
here's the reality
this medieval dude
may or may not have had a smaller than
average penis frankly it seems unfair to
speculate when he's not here to defend
himself against the charge i mean again
just imagine as a man looking down from
heaven a thousand years from now and
seeing a bunch of scientists at your
grave going well
based on the extremely tiny reproductive
organ we can only surmise that this man
wore skirts and lived his life as a
woman that is a truly cosmic form of
humiliation i feel bad for this guy
but all that aside what we know for sure
about this dude is that he was
absolutely not non-binary because
non-binary as a category did not exist a
thousand years ago it didn't even exist
a hundred years ago
this is a very modern
very western innovation
gender identity is a concept that people
came up with
and we know who those people were we
know when and how and why they came up
with it's all documented recently
there are no ancient tablets or papyrus
scrolls describing the lived experiences
of pansexual gender fluid trans women
because none of those labels or ideas
existed
you may as well find a blue shirt in a
bronze age tomb and conclude that the
person must have worked at best buy
perhaps next we can get a research paper
explaining how socrates was the world's
first tic toc influencer i mean it is
that absurd it is that insanely
anachronistic
non-binary is a self-perception
which rests on the idea that sex and
gender are distinct categories and that
one or perhaps both are fluid and
subjective you cannot have non-binary
identifying people without that
intellectual framework to hold up the
entire thing now it's already verging on
quackery to speculate about the
self-perception of a 1 000 year old
skeleton
there's just no way to know but in this
case
we can at least know that however this
guy perceived himself he did not
perceive himself as non-binary because
there was in ancient times no concept
of sex and gender as distinct or or
either one being fluid
there were simply males and females
men and women
some men might have been more feminine
some men might have even cross-dressed
they might have cross-dressed and slept
with other men
yet they were still men everyone knew
they were men
and would not have questioned that fact
it's not that they rejected our
conceptions of gender but more that
those conceptions would have absolutely
would have had absolutely no meaning to
them
they would not have understood what you
were saying if you tried to explain it
those conceptions have no meaning now
either but they are familiar at least
you know this is the irony
the left wants us to reject the past
tear down the statues of our historical
heroes
spit on our ancestor great ancestors
graves and embrace the supposed
revolutionary progress of modern culture
and yet when it comes to their most
their most revolutionary and modern
ideas
they seek cover behind the very
tombstones they were just spitting on
they can't admit that it's revolutionary
and modern they want us to believe that
it's ancient and old
the people of the past were a bunch of
close-minded patriarchal bigoted racist
savages they tell us
but they also had views on gender
identity that would make a pink-haired
nose-pierced 23-year-old antifa rioter
proud
this like everything else they say is
completely incoherent
so to npr and these gender
archaeologists i say
you have already desecrated modern
society enough with this madness
leave the dead alone
you maniacs
also of course
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha thomachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode
pressure ramps up on governor cuomo to
resign the aclu is suing the biden
administration and fake vaccination
cards are on the rise join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know with our show morning wire